winter is coming but first he gave us a
chance to catch our breaths misa we want
to apologize for the background I'm
shooting this while I'm actually doing
some traveling but I want to try and get
my thoughts down while they're still
fresh in my head so this is the last
episode of season 3 on Game of Thrones
and I've heard some people call it
anti-climactic I wouldn't go so that far
it's actually pretty much in keeping
with the tone of most of the last
episodes for the seasons because you
tend to get you really big seminal
moments in the second the last episode
first season it was the execution of Ned
Stark second season it was the Battle of
Blackwater Bay third season had its own
thing going on in the previous episode
so the last episodes isn't usually more
boy winding down and putting us into a
slightly more subdued mode as we wait
for the next season to come out so that
we're not waiting for almost a year on a
complete and total cliffhanger that said
the season finales for the previous two
seasons did at least have one button at
the end to sort of give a little oh yeah
that's new you know the birth of the
Dragons in season one the appearance of
the White Walkers in season to this
season doesn't really have that last
sort of move note at the end of it so it
is I guess a little bit anti-climactic
compared to previous season Enders but
overall tone is still very much
consistent and honestly I'm kind of
appreciative of that because after what
happened in the previous episode which
I'm not going to get into will deal with
spoilers when I do the series overview
but it's nice just to give the audience
a chance to catch their breaths and just
absorb and deal with what went on and
the characters kind of need that too so
this is really just all about setting
the stage and setting the players for
the next season now there are a couple
of specific things that I really like in
this episode you may remember i
mentioned they've put Sansa Stark in a
situation where maybe she could finally
become interesting well she's starting
to nudge that way so I'm crossing my
fingers that she will finally be
interesting to me speaking of stars
ladies Arya get some great moments in
here remember all those romances I was
complaining about before or one of them
appears to have broken up in spectacular
fashion
really kind of hoping it stays that way
although even if they reconcile I'm just
glad that these moments in this episode
happen really taking to Davos The Onion
Knight as well while I hesitated to make
it a direct comparison he's kind of
become the equivalent of Ned Stark in
that he is a character who does not
believe that the ends justify the means
he believes in just being good and not
just doing whatever he can to further
his goals or further as Lords goals or
whatever he's becoming the rock that Ned
was in the first season and the sort of
character that we didn't really have in
the second season yes Davos was
introduced in the second season but we
didn't get to know him and his place in
all this too well now we're getting a
much better sense of him and I love them
Samwell Tarly how cool is this guy
turning out to be and just a lot being
built up that makes me all the more
excited for season 4 to get started in
the spirit of this last episode let me
ask you is your preference for season
finales real big whiz-bang would do you
prefer cliffhangers of you prefer these
sort of choir catch your breath sort of
episodes what's your general preference
leave something down on the comments
let's talk about it and until next time
this council is adjourned